the watcher takes audiences on another
memorable journey in episode two of what
if where they're treated to a story much
different than peggy carter's in episode
one here's episode two explain
as the watcher explained in the premiere
episode one choice can create a new
universe which we saw when peggy opted
to stay on the floor to watch the super
soldier experiment on steve rogers
instead of going up into the booth this
time the focus was on t'challa voiced by
the late great chadwick boseman who
recorded his part before his untimely
death in august 2020. in episode 2 the
choice had a little more humor behind it
we find out immediately when the episode
begins that t'challa is star-lord who in
our reality is peter quill after he was
wrongfully kidnapped from earth by the
ravagers instead of doing it himself
yondu let craglin and tayser face find
and take the boy which opened the door
to this new universe being the complete
morons that they are the men kidnapped
the first boy they saw and figured it
had to be him because he had two
seaholes two here holes and one eathole
instead of returning to chala to wakanda
yondu opted to keep the boy and raised
him as a ravager who are robin hood
asked goodguys kidnapping t'challa
changed the entire universe in ways we
could never have imagined
episode 2 pulls characters from several
different films including black panther
guardians of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy volume 2 and avengers infinity
war fairly quickly we learned that
t'challa convinced thanos to abandon his
plan of murdering trillions by teaching
him how to reallocate the universe's
resources just like that thanos is a
good guy and aids the ravages and their
mission to steal the embers of genesis
from the collector yeah well try calling
me captain genocide again new guy also
aiding the group is nebula who rocks
some wavy blonde hair and appears to be
in her original lupamoid form something
we have never seen before she has some
metal plating around her left eye but
the rest of her body seems untouched
nebula and t'challa have a flirty
relationship which only reminds us that
there is no nakia in this story
t'challa's initial love interest from
black panther however one of the biggest
takeaways here is that the guardians of
the galaxy are never formed there's not
even a new spin on the hero group and
the episode is without gamora groot and
rocket we do get a brief scene with drax
who bartends at an intergalactic club
where t'challa visits it turns out
everyone knows who star-lord is in this
story and drax thanks him for saving his
homeworld which means his wife and
daughter are still alive drax is still a
very blunt literal guy and tells
t'challa he looks terrible in their
photo together some things just never
change
the big mission in the episode is to
steal the aforementioned ember of
genesis nutrient-rich cosmic dust that
can terraform entire ecosystems the
good-natured t'challa sees this as an
opportunity to eradicate hunger across
the galaxy but the rest of the ravager
team which includes star-lord superfan
korath is terrified to go up against the
collector who keeps it in his library
apparently the collector is the new
thanos in this universe after the mad
titan went straight yandu is terrified
to go up against him as are the rest of
the ravagers as they dubbed the heist
suicide with the orb t'challa stole from
morag earlier in their possession nebula
and yondu are able to get a meeting with
the collector who is totally jacked by
the way so they can make their way into
his vault of nowhere the black order who
we initially know as the children of
thanos from infinity war now work for
the shirtless collector in a bizarre
twist we finally meet the collector
adorned with an eight pack that make
dwayne johnson jealous who appears much
more ruthless than the whitetail
eccentric from guardians of the galaxy
oh
that woman has taste a necrosaur
courtesy of the asgardian goddess of
death
the team is successful in stealing the
embers but along the way t'challa
discovers a wakandan ship in the
collector's vault he realizes his
homeland is still thriving and calls out
yondu for lying to him about it being
decimated in the episode's conclusion
the new gang travels to wakanda where
t'challa is reunited with his family
tachaka ramonda and shuri are there to
greet him akaye is also still around
with her pattern changed as she is still
a member of the dora malaysia
t'challa's role as star-lord effectively
stops the snap from ever happening and
his nowhere heist also allows for the
entire universe to be fed that's a much
bigger impact than peggy carter becoming
a super soldier no offense to our new
captain while that's the biggest
takeaway from episode 2 there are plenty
of what-if scenarios to wonder about
that aren't laid out for us there really
isn't a need for the guardians of the
galaxy as we know them especially since
ronan wouldn't be looking for the orb to
serve thanos the cree leader is probably
off battling the scrolls who get a brief
mention in the club scene but he doesn't
seem to be a threat in this universe
killmonger who will appear in another
what-if episode is still out there we
assume but he hasn't arrived in wakanda
yet it's possible he still comes to
challenge the throne because t'challa
becoming star-lord doesn't necessarily
change his story at all also in the
episode's conclusion we see that ego has
traveled to earth on his own and meets
peter who is mopping the floor of a
dairy queen this story could go anywhere
with a naive peter much more likely to
aid his planet of a father than whatever
he might be up to these days
one of the biggest things to ponder from
episode 2 are the deeper ramifications
of t'challa convincing thanos to abort
his genocidal plan this would all boil
down to timing and at what point the mad
titan decided to go straight if it was
done before he began collecting stones
or more importantly before he obtained
the mine stone it would change the
entire mcu from phase 2 and beyond just
go with us on this one as it might sound
a little crazy thanos gives loki the
scepter which holds the mind stone so
he'd have the upper hand on earth as he
thought to obtain the tesseract which
contains the space stone if thanos gives
up his plan before giving loki the
scepter that means the mind stone never
makes its way to earth this simple
change could suggest that the avengers
never formed because without loki the
team would never come together it's as
simple as that if the avengers were
formed one way or another tony stark and
bruce banner never would have gotten
their hands on the mind stone which
would mean no ultron and no vision this
also means baron zemo is happily chowing
down on some paprika with his wife and
children in sokovia he never would have
bombed the united nations meeting in
vienna meaning tachaka is no longer in
danger no mind stone on earth also means
no scarlet witch and quicksilver that
little shiny sucker shaped the mcu more
than any other stone and if t'challa was
star-lord this all might have looked
very different as we said this would all
depend on timing and if thanos had
already sent loki to earth all these
points we've made are mute that's the
point of this series though isn't it
we're left upon to the question what if
oh the watcher would be so proud
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
what if are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]